US THE PEOPLE OF WEST HOLLYWOOD,
CALIFORNIA WERE NOT FRIENDLY
WHEN SHE ASKED ABOUT
HOLLYWOOD TO ASK WHAT THEIR
PROBLEM IS WITH FOX NEWS AND
PEOPLE LIKE ME AND HER.
>> WHERE DO YOU GET YOUR NEWS
FROM?
>> NOT FOX.
>> NOT THE BIGGEST FAN.
>> NEVER FOX NEWS?
>> I'M NOT REALLY A BIG FAN OF
FOX NEWS.
>> I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE I
>> FOX NEWS IS SPEAKING TO YOU
RIGHT NOW.
>> LITERALLY BUT AS FAR AS THEIR
MESSAGE THEY AREN'T SPEAKING TO
>> YOU WALKED PAST ME, YOU SAID
THERE'S FOX NEWS, YOU HAD A
REACTION, YOU SAW THE MIKE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF FOX NEWS?
>> NO FOX.
>> YOU HAD SOME THOUGHTS.
NO THOUGHTS SNIRM EEP NOT TRYING
TO GET YOU HERE, I WANT TO KNOW.
>> I TEND TO GET MY NEWS FROM
>> HAVE YOU EVER SEEN MY VILDOS
ON FACEBOOK.
>> I HAVE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN HIGH
VIDEOS COME ON.
>> I GIVE EVERYBODY A CHANCE, I
>> THEY TOLD ME THIS PLACE IS
ABOUT LOVE, TOLERANCE,
WELCOMING.
YOU SEE ME OUT HERE, YOU KNOW
WHO I AM, YOU CALL ME TAMMY,
THAT'S FINE, PUT IT BEHIND US.
BUT YOU SAW ME WITH THE FOX NEWS
MIKE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WERE FOX NEWS?
>> I DON'T LIKE IT.
AND I DON'T REALLY LIKE A LOT OF
YOUR ANCHORS.
>> I THINK THAT SEAN HANNITY IS
EXTREMELY INTERESTING OF A
PERSON.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> INTERESTING PERSON.
A GUY WITH A LOT OF INNER AND OF
THOR DEMONS.
>> UNFORTUNATE PERSON TO HAVE IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT.
>> ISN'T THAT WEIRD THAT THE
AREA THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
LOVING, TOLERANT TO EVERYONE?
>> WELCOME TO THE BIGGEST
ANOMALY.
>> YOU THINK WEST HOLLYWOOD IS
AN ANOMALY?
>> ONLY WHEN YOUR VIEWS MATCH
THEIR VIEWS.
>> EVERY NEWS SOURCE IS BIASED.
THERE'S TWO SIDES TO EVERY STORY
AND THEN THE TRUTH.
>> YOU WATCH THEM ALL?
>> THEN YOU GET CRAZIER.
>> I GET MY COMEDY FROM FOX NEWS
AND MY NEWS FROM COMEDIANS.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK YOU CALLED
ME TAMMY, WAS THAT 100%
RESPECTFUL?
>> I'M SORRY TA IF THAT HURT
YOUR FEELINGS.
>> I WOULD NEVER CALL YOU SOME
ONE OUTSIDE OF YOUR NAME.
>> BARISTAS GET MY NAME WRONG.
>> BUT YOU DELIBERATELY GOT MINE
WRONG TO BE MEAN.
>> I'M SORE I.
SORRY.
RN S WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
FANS.
>> YEAH.
I'M NOT SURE, I DIDN'T REALLY
HEAR WHAT YOUR INNER OR OUTWARD
DEMONS WERE.
PROBLEMATIC.
MANY OF THEM DON'T WATCH FOX
NEWS.
I THINK THEY'RE JUST GUESSING.
I'M NOT SURE.
>> Sean: DID YOU GET ANYBODY
THAT LIKED SNUGS I DIDN'T SEE
ONE PERSON THAT LIKED US.
>> THEY COULDN'T BE VOCAL ABOUT
IT.
HAT," BUT THEY WOULDN'T EVEN
WEAR A RED HAT.
THEM WOULDN'T HAVE FRIENDS.
>> Sean: I HAVE A GREAT IDEA FOR
NEXT WEEK, GO BACK TO WEST
THE COMFORT OF THE STUDIO.
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK AND YOU HAVE
TO WEAR A "MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN" HAT AND OFFER THEM FOR
I AM ABSOLUTELY, YOU HEARD IT
HERE FIRST, I'M GOING BACK TO
SHOULD DO IT TO CELEBRATE THE
ONE YEAR OF HIS INAUGURATION.
LET'S CELEBRATE ONE YEAR OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I'LL GO BACK
TO WEST HOLLYWOOD.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO GET A SIGNED.
YOU HAVE TO GET A HAT AND JERSEY
SIGNED.
YOU CAN SAY THIS IS REALLY
SIGNED BY THE PRESIDENT.
AND SEE WHAT THEY DO.
OR WE'LL FORGE HIS SIGNATURE TO
MAKE FUN, TELL THEM THE TRUTH
AFTER.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TIME.
THEN WE COULD SAY WOULD YOU LIKE
A PRESIDENTIAL SIGNED CAP.
THEN YOU COULD SAY IT'S NOT
REALLY SIGNED AFTER THEY GIVE
THEIR RESPONSE.
CNN.
>> HOW MUCH EXTRA SECURITY ARE